est creux à Cuba les dissidans sont
partagés entre espoir et scepticisme
après l'annonce de la retraite de Fidel
Castro voici le premier reportage de
notre envoyé spécial Christian Autin
Alain Havane il vient de nous parvenir
au lendemain de l'annonce de son retrait
définitif Fidel Castro fait encore la
Une de gramma l'organe officiel cubain
ici la nouvelle n'a pas surpris depuis
18 mois les Cubains ont eu le temps de
s'habituer à l'absence du leader maximo
on salue ici la décision du commandant
en chef d'avoir quitté le pouvoir
volontairement
de son vivant
je ne suis plus en mesure de diriger ce
pays
mais quand on demande ce qui va changer
dimanche prochain avec l'élection du
successeur de Fidel Castro certains ne
se font guère d'illusions
un avis qui n'est pas partagé par tout
le monde devant une caméra étrangère
certains cubes n'hésitent plus
aujourd'hui à souhaiter une évolution du
régime qu'il juge nécessaire et sans
rejeter le socialisme
il nous faut améliorer le système
améliorer notre socialisme mais pas
devenir capitaliste
c'est dimanche prochain qu'on connaîtra
le successeur de Fidel Castro selon
toute vraisemblance c'est Raoul Castro
actuel président par intérim qui devrait
lui succéder en tout état de cause
celui-ci devra s'atteler à réformer le
pays pour remettre à flot l'économie